you broke my life saying that I think
the secret is out
solo nearly 20 years in the making mall
is back in live-action Star Wars I mean
you talk a little bit about how that
call came up and did you ever think
you'd be appearing in the live-action
sense again it was a hope when Clone
Wars came out rebels it was kind of one
of those the new movies being made it
could be a possibility been a new
character I always wished if they did
ask me back and gave me a choice to be a
character I'd be I wouldn't mind being
about like a Mandalorian but I didn't
actually think I'd be cool back for solo
when you're reprising your role was
there any hesitation at all just because
so much time at pasture were you
instantly like yes I'm in yes right away
when I got a call from Lucasfilm hey Rey
so we have some good news I've been
asked they bring you back home would you
like to do it no yep come on plane I'm
coming I'm doing it now when Janine hmm
no hesitation I've shaved my hair again
how much action do I need to do okay my
one pack okay could I get a pack again
and so I didn't need to do any action
and it was such a taste of the character
that I think fans are clamoring for for
so long
did that make you maybe want let's just
hypothetically throw something out there
if there's a live-action series or a
solo mall movie would you instantly be
on board for that if there's a
live-action is a solo mode movie there's
a not you name it I want to do Kira you
can die
we'll be working much more closely from
now on we do get that that final moment
where Kira is on her way to see Mall on
Dathomir do you think we'll ever see
kind of held up I was speaking to samba
voice you voice more first they're so
loud I'm like she's coming to get us
you guys know it's not possible right
what happened I'm not no no besides I
love I hope it happens you know like I'm
my money speaking as a fan I don't have
any information mmm there's a lot of
things I hear from fans there's a lot of
thing
theories says a lot I mean I would love
to have a Darth Maul movie where it's
just silent most his action well he does
do a lot with just the expression alone
compressional yeah yeah and I kind of
want you to show me like the perfect
smolder I kind of dressed like mall
today and I have a secret for you I was
a flag twirler in high school and I feel
like that might help my light scale the
Sabre skills a little bit definitely
yeah are you willing to show me didn't
do sorry yeah what you're doing is
really good I love it
I could show you reverse great okay
missed a few steps here
inside outside and polls
- right no that's all right as they will
heavier yeah I broke it
oh my god actually broke him you broke
my lifesaver
that's a Jedi pose yeah show me the
skills
[Applause]